c'est du jamais vu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale il n'y aura pas de
défilé syndical ce 1er mai l'an dernier
la mobilisation avait réuni salariés et
gilet jaune
ils étaient entre 150 milles et 300000
partout en france
pourtant malgré le confinement pas
question pour les syndicats de manquer
ce rendez vous traditionnel
nous porterons ce 1er mai 2020 bien que
confiné les revendications qui sont plus
que jamais d'actualité
sacrifier la santé des travailleurs
n'est pas admissible sacrifier les
droits des travailleurs sur l'autel de
l'économie n'est pas tolérable et ne
pourra continuer quelle que soit la
situation
sacrifier les plus précaires d'entre
nous n'est pas admissible dans une
société d'égalité et de solidarité
situation sanitaire oblige
la mobilisation doit se réinventer
manifestation sur la toile où depuis sa
fenêtre ou son balcon tous les moyens
sont bons pour manifester ailleurs que
dans la rue va falloir s'habituer à ce
qu'il y ait d'autres modes de
fonctionnement social et politique
on sait très bien que les grandes
révolutions ce soit dans les printemps
arabes ou ailleurs ont été déclenchées
initiés porte est alimenté par par les
réseaux sociaux donc c'est pas une
nouveauté bon le fait et c'est que
demain ça va remplacer complètement des
rassemblements qui avaient aussi lieu
dans l'espace dans l'espace public
donc je pense que est évidemment pour
beaucoup c'est une parenthèse dans une
vie sociale qui chacun l'espère
reprendra son rythme normal un petit peu
un petit peu plus tard
paradoxalement c'était assez symbolique
qu'on célèbre demain une fête du travail
alors que plus de 10 millions de
personnes sont en chômage partiel que
probablement beaucoup licencié ne
retrouveront pas leur activité
donc ça peut être aussi une sorte
d'appel au travail
1une fait de la lutte contre le chômage
l'association réaction 19 qui prépare
l'après qu'ovide 19 avait par exemple
prévu un rassemblement ce 1er mai au
trocadéro elle s'est rapidement vu
notifier une interdiction de manifester
par la préfecture de police de paris
une décision qualifiée d'injuste par le
président de l'association
nous avons écrit que les personnes
allaient s'installer sur le parvis avec
une distance de à mettre 2002 m chacun
pourtant des gants et portant des
masques à respectant ce qu'on appelle
les gestes barrière je disais nous
verrez il y aura peut-être le premier
mais des personnes qui vont s'arrêter et
resteront un silence pendant une heure
pour appeler les victimes de kobe 19
c'est une atteinte aux principes
essentiels de la liberté d'aller et
venir de la liberté de circuler de la
liberté d'expression de la liberté de
manifester parce que le confinement tels
qu'ils étaient conçus en france il était
adopté
parce qu'il n'ya pas les lits
nécessaires et une structure
hospitalière qui pouvait affronter
retraite pouvoir d'achat égalité sociale
est désormais chômage de masse s'il est
impossible de se rassembler en ces temps
de confinement le mois de septembre
s'annonce d'ores et déjà placé sous le
signe des revendications sociales